Black Friday is coming up,
Cyber Monday is coming up.
There's gonna be so many fucking deals.
If you have a lot of kids,
like I have a lot of kids
and you need to get a lot of fucking gifts,
the TikTok shop is gonna be your best friend.
And so I get a lot of samples and shit.
I try a lot of shit from the TikTok shop.
I have children, lots of them. Boy, girl,
teenage, not teenage.
All the shit I'm gonna tell you
the shit that's like worth buying and not worth buying.
Or sometimes, like,
we don't know, like,
what the kids think is cool.
My daughter has like approved many of these things.
Have been like, oh my god,
mom, can I have that?
These makeup brushes. First of all,
it comes with a kit with a ton of shit.
You get like this type of shit in the little things.
I don't have any of it cause my daughter's already stole all of it.
This is like the little bit I could cling to.
It's linked right here if you wanna buy it,
because it comes with a bunch of shit.
Even with my daughter stealing half of it,
I still have enough of my own.
And also, you could just get it for your daughters
cause they're. You know what I mean?
Like, don't waste your fucking time thinking it's gonna be yours.
Just get it and give it to your daughters.
Because with the buck Friday deals,
the Cyber Monday deals, the coupons and shit,
you can really afford to, like,
make Christmas a big deal for your kids.
So if you have teenage girls,
this makeup set, this makeup brush set is a big fucking hit. Big hit.